[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Wednesday January 25th I'm Zoe Thomas
for The Wall Street Journal
the justice department wants to break up
Google's digital advertising business
the doj filed an Anti-Trust lawsuit
against the tech giant yesterday
claiming it abuses its role as one of
the largest Brokers suppliers and
auctioneers of online ads the case could
have wide-ranging implications for the
digital advertising industry and for
Google which is also facing other
regulatory lawsuits and challenges in
the U.S and Europe joining me to talk
about this is our Google reporter miles
Krupa hi miles thanks for joining us
thank you can you start by explaining to
us what exactly the justice department
is alleging
so the justice department is focused
here on what we call Google's ad Tech
business which is basically
these tools they own that allow websites
and other online Publishers to sell ad
slots to Big Brands and then allows big
Brands to come and bid on those ad slots
the justice department is basically
alleging that Google used a series of
Acquisitions that go back all the way to
to build up a business in ad Tech that
ended up being anti-competitive harmed
Rivals drove up prices in the market and
effectively created a monopoly on these
really widely used tools that are
important to the functioning of the
internet
bonded to these allegations
so this isn't Google's first rodeo
facing these kinds of allegations
there's already a lawsuit led by Texas
and joined by a bunch of other states
that's very similar and Google's
response has basically been we've
already responded to all this stuff and
the doj is retreading old ground and
trying to pick favors they say in the
online advertising technology Market a
Google spokesman said quote doj is
doubling down on a flawed argument that
would slow Innovation raise advertising
fees and make it harder for thousands of
small businesses and Publishers to grow
and mean you mentioned the Acquisitions
that the doj is alleging are problematic
I mean is that how Google got to be such
a big player in this space in many ways
it did because Google's first big
advertising business of course was
selling ads on its search engine it then
realized that it basically had an
opportunity to do the same for the rest
of the internet and once it realized
that it started very aggressively buying
up competitors startups creating useful
tools for ad buyers and AD sellers
and over the course of what must have
been at least half a dozen or so
Acquisitions it built this really big ad
Tech stack as people in the industry
call it in this isn't the whole of
Google or its parent company alphabets
advertising business right no it's
actually really a relatively small slice
when you compare it to the core search
advertising business so in 2021 the
revenues Google brought in from this
business we're about 12 percent of the
total and of those revenues roughly 70
percent or two-thirds depending on who
you ask go out to the online Publishers
themselves you mentioned this isn't
Google's only battle it's not its first
rodeo what are the other challenges
lawsuits regulatory concerns that it's
having to deal with at the moment right
one of the more interesting wrinkles
with this is that the doj has already
sued Google once on antitrust grounds
and that case hasn't even made it to
trial yet so in 2020 the doj sued Google
focusing on the search business and
Partnerships is striked with other
companies to ensure that Google search
is the default in many settings such as
in browsers and on phones
and so in some ways this is just the
latest development in a long line of
antitrust complaints against Google both
in the US and Europe which by the way is
looking into some of the same
allegations so it won't be anytime soon
that Google is done with these cases how
big could the implications of this case
be I mean the online advertising
industry is huge the doj estimates that
there's at least 20 billion dollars a
year just in display advertising on the
internet and if you talk to Executives
in the industry you hear sort of mixed
opinions on what would happen if
Google's ad Tech business was broken up
like the doj wants it to be some people
say it would encourage competition it
would lead to a Freer market for these
services but others actually say that
Google by building this ad stack that's
really integrated has created
efficiencies in some ways so I think all
of that will be sorted out years from
now but I think people are just starting
to wrap their heads around what this
could mean so what comes next then in
this case it'll be a while before we get
the next I think Google will reply with
its own response to the allegations in a
filing and then
we'll go through a good amount of back
and forth on what can be kept in the
case and what what gets tossed out so
it's a long road and we're only at the
beginning all right that was our
reporter miles Krupa thanks for joining
us miles thank you and that's it for
today's Tech news briefing for more Tech
stories check out our website
wsj.com I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall
Street Journal thanks for listening
[Music]